die einen nennen ist ein skandal die
nächsten sagen das wäre kein guter tag
für die demokratie oder ein schwarzer
tag für das land sogar nur die afd
die feiert das in thüringen ein neuer
ministerpräsident gewählt wurde obwohl
er nicht aus der afg kommt sondern von
der fdp der neue ministerpräsident hier
im bild heißt thomas kemmerich
er ist der chef der fdp in thüringen und
dies bei der wahl im oktober ja
eigentlich nur echt ganz haarscharf
überhaupt in den landtag gekommen 73
stimmen über der fünf prozent hürde
die kleinste fraktion im ganzen land tag
zusammen mit den grünen jeweils fünf
stimmen also insgesamt jetzt nicht die
besten voraussetzungen um der neue
landesvater zu werden und trotzdem ist
herr kemmerich jetzt ministerpräsident
in thüringen und das ganze ist so
gelaufen dass es insgesamt drei
wahlgänge gab in den ersten beiden hat
er es nicht geschafft da als auch bodo
ramelow nicht die absolute mehrheit
bekommen die er brauchte und dann gab es
den dritten wahlgang reichte die
einfache mehrheit und auf einmal hat die
afg nicht mehr für ihren eigenen
kandidaten gestimmt sondern für hirn
kämpferisch absolut geschlossen keine
stimme mehr daten alle an die fdp
das war eine große überraschung denn
eigentlich waren eigentlich davon alle
davon ausgegangen dass bodo ramelow also
der bisherige ministerpräsident von den
linken der die wahl auch gewonnen hatte
der neue ministerpräsident wird jetzt
ist es nicht mehr so und wer jetzt nicht
so richtig durchblickt was da eigentlich
alles passiert ist heute oder was da
jetzt kommt er darf sehr gerne seine
fragen hier unten in die kommentare
posten oder auch ein kommentar dazu ab
lassen wir gucken uns das nachher an
aber erst mal erklärt hagen nicolas noch
mal was da heute genau passiert ist
es ist ein politisches erdbeben mit fdp
chef thomas kemmerich wird jemand als
ministerpräsident vereidigt mit dem kaum
jemand rechnete der 54 jährige führt die
mit fünf abgeordneten kleinste fraktion
im landtag bei der wahl im oktober
schaffte die fdp knapp die fünf prozent
hürde
und nun soll sie eine
koalitionsregierung organisieren die
fortsetzung der rot rot grünen koalition
unter dem bisherigen amtsinhaber bodo
ramelow ist nach drei wahlgängen
gescheitert und das durch stimmen der
afd
rot-rot-grün ringt um worte
thüringen thüringen eindeutig mit ihrem
wahlergebnis zum ausdruck gebracht
werden sie als ministerpräsident haben
wollen und was die fdp hier für ein
spiel getrieben hat das missachtet
einfach den wählerwillen alles kam so
gegen den bisherigen linken
ministerpräsidenten ramelow tritt
zunächst der parteilose
ortsbürgermeister christoph kindervater
für die afg an
im dritten wahlgang stellt die fdp
thomas kemmerich als kandidatin auf er
erhält 45 stimmen eine mehr als bodo
ramelow kfd kandidat kindervater bekommt
0 stimmen denn alle fdp abgeordneten
stimmen für fdp-chef kemmerich die cdu
sieht die wahl kammerichs gerechtfertigt
wenn zwei kandidaten zur auswahl stehen
von der afg und von der linkspartei
und es gibt ein angebot aus der mitte
dann ist es daher folgerichtig dass die
cdu die sich als partei der mitte sieht
auch diesen mitte kandidaten unterstützt
und dazwischen rufen nutzt
ministerpräsident thomas kemmerich seine
erste rede vor dem landtag für
distanzierende worte und seine
vorstellung einer minderheitsregierung
spreche eine einladung an cdu spd und
grüne aus gemeinsam staatspolitische
verantwortung für thüringen wahrzunehmen
wer kemmerich gewählt hat hat ein
erbitterten gegner von allem gewählt was
auch nur einen hauch von radikalismus
rechts wie links faschismus aufweist
während die cdu zur zusammenarbeit
bereit ist haben spd und grüne ihre
ablehnung erklärt so also ziemlich große
überraschung ein etwas merkwürdiger tag
heute im thüringischen landtag darüber
spreche ich heute mit benjamin köhler
der das politische
politikwissenschaftler und
stellvertretender leiter des instituts
für parlamentarismus forschung so jetzt
hammers aber herr höhne in berlin
wie würden sie das beschreiben fasst er
heute in thüringen im landtag passiert
ist ganz schwierige situation mit der
glaube ich die wenigsten so gerechnet
hätten insofern dass viele kalt erwischt
und es geht ein desaströses signal von
thüringen für die gesamte bundesrepublik
aus und auch für mich ist noch nicht
klar
was wird denn das für eine regierung mit
handkamera an der spitze von der fdp
wer soll diese regierung unterstützen
wie lange kann sie sich überhaupt halten
oder was heute auch schon vorüber heute
auch schon spekuliert wird müssen wir
alle
mit neuen waren in thüringen rechnen was
ist denn das für ein desaströses signal
was sie gerade meinten was da von
thüringen ausgeht
das ist das erste mal dass die kfd
sozusagen dazu beigetragen hat dass ein
ministerpräsident mit ihrer zustimmung
gewählt wird es gibt ja nun verschiedene
beschlüsse von einem parteien nicht mit
der ard zusammenarbeiten zu wollen
das gilt auch für die cdu und die fdp
sollte man sich auch im wahlkampf
eindeutig positioniert und nun lässt man
sich dann doch mit den stimmen der fdp
gehen
das ist natürlich kein gutes signal und
ich habe da braucht die fdp sich auch
nicht so ein stück weit naiv hinstellen
und sagen wir sind halt angetreten und
können ja nichts dafür wer uns wählt ist
das so wer antritt und sich wählen lässt
muss auch damit rechnen am ende gewählt
zu werden und auch stimmen von parteien
zu bekommen die man vielleicht nicht
unbedingt haben möchte
was ist denn das für eine taktik gewesen
von der afg die haben quasi am
wochenende auf einmal einen kandidaten
aus dem hut gezaubert den bis dahin
wirklich niemand kannte der ist bis
jetzt parteiisch partei nicht gar nicht
aufgetreten
er ist parteilos gehört nicht so afd den
haben sie dann zweimal gewählt und dem
dritten bayern auf einmal gar nicht mehr
was ist das quasi das kalkül dahinter
gewesen ja schwer zu durchschauen
also kann ich auch nur spekulieren ich
würde aber davor waren das einfach als
zufällige ereignisse darzustellen
es ist schon der verdacht im raum dass
da in den hinterzimmern gespräche und
vorbereitungen liefen die dann zu dem
ergebnis geführt haben dass wir heute in
thüringen beobachten können meinen sie
denn dass die fdp da irgendwie wind von
bekommen hat und dann doch irgendwie
mitgemacht hat oder ist die eiskalt
überrascht worden
gute frage kann ich auch nur spekulieren
ich meine die fdp war ja bis vor kurzem
in einer sehr sehr schwierigen situation
sie wie es aus dem bundestag gefallen
christian lindner hat sie neu
aufgerichtet und dabei eigentlich die
fdp auch so positioniert dass sie nicht
der versuchung unterlag irgendwo
in richtung rechtspopulismus zu blinken
also hat sie sozusagen auf einem mit
einem liberalen kurs gehalten und sich
auch distanziert sehr deutlich und nun
sie wir haben uns auch an das zitat von
christian lindner weshalb er nicht in
die jamaika koalition auf bundesebene
gehen sollte wo er sagte lieber gar
nicht regieren als schlecht regieren und
nun fragt man sich was gilt denn davon
noch in thüringen und welchem weg möchte
die fdp da bestreiten also viele offene
frage zeichen wenn ihr fragen habt oder
kommentare könnte jetzt die sehr gerne
stellen ich habe hier schon so ein paar
weil das thema doch viele menschen
bewegt zum beispiel gibt es ja einen
kommentar von eltern die nie 77 auf
periskop meint bei den nächsten wahlen
wird die fdp nicht mehr rein kommt das
ist jetzt natürlich auch spekulation
aber klar die sind nur sehr sehr knapp
reingekommen in den landtag letztes jahr
dort braker 21 sagt die fdp die afg
wurde auch gewählt tut doch nicht immer
so als wenn die was besonderes fähren
können sie das verstehen lassen ist die
afg was besonderes oder einfach dann
doch nur eine partei die jetzt mal ein
bisschen den landtag aufgemischt hat
naja mein eindruck ist der dass man oder
dass die etablierten parteien ein stück
weit die brisanz der afg nicht so
richtig sehen oder das in eine richtung
bringen die richtung ignorieren geht
also das heißt im prinzip machen sie an
vielen stellen so weiter wie sie das
über jahrzehnte lang gemacht haben also
das heißt man hat die große koalition
man hat linke bündnisse rechte bündnisse
und man sieht dass haut nicht mehr so
ganz hin also nimmt man bei der großen
koalition in sachsen anhalt zum beispiel
noch eine kleinere partei dazu aus den
zweierbündnis und ein dreier bündnissen
und sonst geht alles so weiter wie man
das bisher gemacht hat und ich glaube
das ist ein gewisser weise in den
trugschluss dass man politik neu denken
muss auch bündnisoptionen neu bedenken
muss auch anders ganz anders über
minderheitsregierung nachdenken muss um
da zu einem realistischeren bild über
politik wie sie heutzutage funktioniert
durch das hinzukommen der 8d am ende zu
kommen
naja die fdp war das die erste frage war
ja die platz im osten der bundesrepublik
traditionell nicht leicht die ist ja
gerade so in den thüringer landtag
eingezogen und der fdp geht es ja
zurzeit darum das profil wiederum als
liberale partei zu schärfen und da ist
die frage ob ihr der schachzug vom
heutigen tage tatsächlich gut getan hat
also sich von der afg quasi ins amt
wählen zu lassen darf frage thomas
kemmerich ist jetzt nicht besonders
bekannt bundesweit bislang zumindest
seit heute spätestens aber schon können
sie ein paar worte zu dem herrn sagen
was ist was hat der für einen liter
wasser den hintergrund gibt es da
irgendwie so ein link zur afd dass man
sagen kann ach das macht sinn oder ist
das jetzt eigentlich völlig aus der luft
gegriffen nähe sehe ich nicht so also
das ist da irgendein inhaltlichen link
oder irgendeine inhaltliche schnittmenge
geben würde wo man herrn kemmerich in
die nähe zur afg oder zum
rechtspopulismus bringen könnte da nicht
auch wenn man sich den wahlkampf an
schaut er tritt an der einen stelle doch
recht unkonventionell auf insofern war
das aus meiner perspektive gar nicht zu
erwarten was wir heute gesehen haben und
womöglich hat es ihn tatsächlich auch
selbst ein stück weit überrascht nur
muss man dann sagen wer sich zur wahl
stellt muss damit rechnen also noch
einmal und dann hat man ja immerhin auch
noch die möglichkeit zu sagen man nimmt
eine wahl nicht an
beides hat er gemacht da können wir kurz
mal anwalt hat von ihm zeigen das passt
ganz gut das ist auch etwas
unkonventionell das ist hier auf meinem
bildschirm gerade dafür sieht er vor
seinen eigenen plakat und drauf steht
endlich eine klasse die in geschichte
aufgepasst hat halo übermorgen
finden sie dass dieser spruch jetzt noch
gilt naja zumindest im wahlkampf war das
eine verbindung aus einer gewissen
unkonventionalität vielleicht auch ein
bisschen humor und trotzdem auch den auf
den ernst der sache oder auf unsere
vergangenheit in deutschland abziehen
und nun lässt man sich von von der afg
in thüringen wählen die als eine als der
landesverband in deutschland gilt der
weitesten in der afg rechts steht mit
einer spitzen figur böcke also da gibt
es glaube ich weniger schön zu reden so
ich gucke jetzt mal gerne in die
kommentare deswegen mich darauf
geschrieben weil ich eine spannende
frage ihr habt ich aber später stellen
möchte ich schau mal hier ist es gibt
wirklich sehr sehr viele kommentare dazu
vielleicht gucken wir mal bei youtube
rein was da so geschrieben wird oder ich
guck mal in unserer social media
kommentare tool da hat meine kollegin
nina schon mal ein bisschen gesammelt
mal schauen was da so steht
william kühn möchte wissen auf facebook
wie kann man die wahl annehmen wenn man
wissen sollte wer eingewählt hat das
hätte herr kemmerich wissen können als
gesagt wurde dass der afg kandidat 0
stimmen hat und er eine stimme mehr als
herr ramelow
so wie kann man das machen dann hat man
habe ich auch ganz kurz gezögert hat das
war zumindest so mein eindruck
das ist ja der punkt also hätte die war
ja durchaus nicht annehmen müssen wenn
er vorhatte einfach nur ein zählkandidat
zu sein
da hat er gesagt jetzt wurde er
tatsächlich gewählt hat die wahl
angenommen und nun liegt der ball
tatsächlich bei ihm aber ich sehe nicht
wirklich wie das zu einer stabilen
regierung führen soll ja so hat die cdu
womöglich auf seiner seite
sie haben auch keine mehrheit im
parlament die linken parteien
insbesondere die linkspartei die heute
ihren ministerpräsidenten quasi in
thüringen verloren hat über den teufel
tun nämlich an die fdp und die cdu zu
unterstützen
selbiges gilt mit sicherheit für die
grünen und wahrscheinlich auch für die
spd also bleibt nur die afd
und das wird man genau so nicht wollen
das würde auch gegen beschlüsse
verstoßen also man hätte massivste
konflikte mit der bundesebene das können
wir in ruhe angucken ich hab mal dass
aufgerufen die ergebnisse der
landtagswahl thüringen 2009 10 das
sitzverteilung die linke 29 stärkste
fraktion die spd 18 15 fdp 5 cdu 21 11
die 22 so wenn man zusammen rechnet die
fdp hat jetzt den ministerpräsidenten
die möchten gerne mit der cdu und der
spd und den grünen also den kleineren
fraktionen zusammen jetzt eine regierung
bilden kommen so auf 39 stimmen oder
mandate sitze sind also nicht
beschlussfähig sondern müssten dann
immer gucken dass sie sich von irgendwo
eine mehrheit organisieren
die linke kann man davon ausgehen haben
sie gerade gesagt macht er nicht mit die
afd müsste dann immer mit ins boot
geholt werden gab es dann schon
irgendwie reaktion dass die afg gesagt
hat ja was machen wir dann guck doch mal
was ihr uns so anbieten können wir klar
die auf der behauptet dass sie
mitregieren möchte dass sie
verantwortung übernehmen möchte aber
auch das ist mit dem fragezeichen zu
versehen
weil wenn sie regierungsverantwortung
tatsächlich übernehmen sollte sich dann
die populistische karte die sie spielt
an vielen stellen ja gar nicht mehr so
auch spielen lässt also zb eliten kritik
oder kritik an den verantwortlichen in
regierungsämter
also insofern ist das mit einem
fragezeichen auch ein stück weit zu
versehen
wissen sie was mich persönlich selbst
auch verwundert ist dass das man ja im
vorfeld der durchaus vertrackten
situation in thüringen also eine relativ
starke linkspartei mit annes vater bodo
ramelow der auch stimmen außerhalb der
linken bekommen wir bei der wahl dann
die cdu eine starke a steht also dass
man um diese vertrackte situation wusste
verschiedene koalitions optionen
ausgelotet hat gesehen hat eigentlich
funktioniert keine koalition wie man sie
bisher kennt man muss also neue wege
gehen und hätte man ja offen alle karten
auf den tisch legen können und auch
diese option durchaus durchspielen
können dass man sagt also wir einigen
uns jetzt auch die fdp als kleinste
partei mit der gibt es vielleicht
schnittmengen zu einem anderen parteien
aber warum hat man das im vorfeld nicht
gemacht ja die frage muss man
wahrscheinlich der fdp in thüringen
unter anderem unter linken aufstellen
das ganze hat für ziemlich große
aufregung gesorgt nicht nur in thüringen
sondern natürlich auch im politischen
berlin wohl glaube ich einige parteien
und einige parteichefs ziemlich kalt
überrascht wurden wir haben da mal die
aktuellen reaktionen zusammengefasst das
hat in die häscher für uns getan
franziska brantner trifft auf wolfgang
kubicki man kann auch sagen wut trifft
auf verteidigung
wunderbar mit diesen vergleichen der fdp
chef versucht maximale abgrenzung die
landtagsfraktion habe in eigener
verantwortung gehandelt
die fdp verhandelt und kooperiert mit
der afd nicht es gibt keine basis für
eine zusammenarbeit
wir unterstützen die ziele und werte
dieser partei nicht
wer umgekehrt unsere kandidaten in einer
geheimen wahl unterstützt
das liegt nicht in unserer macht die afg
spielt mit der antwort inwieweit es
vorabsprachen mit fdp und cdu ab es kam
nicht überraschend
die cdu-chefin alt an den kameras vorbei
den nachfragen davon
sie hat für später ein statement
angekündigt ihr generalsekretär
kritisiert die eigenen leute in
thüringen
umso schlimmer ist dass offensichtlich
auch abgeordnete der cdu thüringen
billigend in kauf genommen haben dass
durch ihre stimmabgabe ein neuer
ministerpräsident auch mit den stimmen
von nazis wie herrn röcke und anderen
der afg fraktion in thüringen gewählt
werden konnte der koalitionspartner in
berlin spricht von einem dammbruch
es kommt jetzt darauf an welche
konsequenzen gezogen werden es gibt
nicht mit einer kommentierung dessen was
passiert ist es geht auch nicht mit
verdammen des ergebnisses und dann
weitermachen als wäre nichts geschehen
wäre
vize-kanzler scholz wird auf twitter
deutlicher der tabubruch habe
auswirkungen weit über thüringen hinaus
da stellen sich für uns sehr ernste
fragen an die spitze der bundes cdu
fragen hat markus söder
der bayerische ministerpräsident nicht
mehr die cdu erleidet damit einen hohen
maß an glaubwürdigkeit zurück für die
csu kann ich nur sagen wir werden uns an
keiner solchen abenteuer sollten sie
hier auf bundesebene anstehen in
irgendeiner form beteiligen ganz im
gegenteil wir lehnen ein solches
verfahren ab
völlig überrascht von den ereignissen
steht auch der linken-chef im pulli vor
der kamera es war eine der übelsten
tricksereien und betrug am willen der
wähler und wählerinnen in thüringen was
wir heute dort erlebt haben ob thüringen
eine blaupause für berlin sein kann
genau das ist jetzt die politische frage
in berlin ja ziemlich große aufregung
also in berlin wir sprechen damit heute
mit benjamin darüber heute nicht wenn
ihr mir in höhe der als
politikwissenschaftler aber bevor wir
ihnen jetzt noch mal zu wort kommen
lassen mit euren fragen löchern das sind
viele haben wir noch gerade rein
bekommen eine äußerung der cdu chefin
annegret kramp karrenbauer die hat sich
in straßburg vor wenigen minuten zu
diesem vorgang wie folgt geäußert
es war aus meiner sicht falsch dass ich
der thüringische ministerpräsident ohne
eigene mehrheit zur wahl gestellt hat es
ist genauso falsch dass es jetzt einen
ministerpräsidenten gibt er mit den
stimmen der fdp gewählt worden ist
wir haben für die cdu immer ganz
deutlich gesagt und das ist unsere
beschlusslage es gibt keine
zusammenarbeit nicht mit lebens und
nicht mit rechts auf diesem grund hat
die cdu in thüringen auch keinen eigenen
kandidaten gestellt weil klar war dass
ein solcher nur mit den stimmen der afg
gewählt werden würde so also ziemlich
große verwirrung aufregung man zeigt mit
dem finger aufeinander haben wir auch
gerade schon besprochen herr höhne
politikwissenschaftler stellvertretender
leiter des instituts für
parlamentarismus forschung jetzt habe
ich richtig gesagt sehr gut hier kam gar
die frage auf sie haben das auch schon
angesprochen wenn die afg quasi jetzt
doch irgendwie an die macht käme
beteiligt werden würde zumindest als
duldung dieser minderheitsregierung in
thüringen dann hörte man sie ja
teilweise integrieren könnte nicht mehr
die karte spielen desjenigen der immer
gegen das establishment vorgeht sondern
sie wäre quasi mittendrin
da kam mir die frage auf wäre das nicht
eher ein weg sie zu integrieren und hier
auch quasi ein stück der munition zu
nehmen gute frage
wir haben in dem beitrag ja auch das
vorweg geschickte gesehen dass der
bundesspitze ziemlich die hände gebunden
ist in einen parteien was die parteien
auf land
wir machen was sozusagen die idee der
einhebung der afd durch die cdu
anbelangt das ist in der tat eine idee
die die cdu auch schon praktiziert hat
mit der deutschen parteien nach 1949 in
den kabinetten in drei kabinetten von
adenauer
da ist die deutsche partei die rechts
neben der cdu stand dann auch irgendwann
in der cdu aufgegangen also dass das
geglückt werden uns dann die
schill-partei
da ist das mehr oder minder auch
geglückt jetzt ist die situation doch
ein stück weit eine andere weil die cdu
im osten und haben auch noch mal eine
andere situation als im westen und im
bund insgesamt über die cdu im osten
natürlich wesentlich schwächer da steht
und die afg wesentlich stärker da steht
also wenn man sich wenn beide parteien
sich irgendwie aufeinander zubewegen
dann steht oder ist es noch offene frage
wer am ende wen vereinnahmt oder wen
schluckt hier kommt auch die frage auf
fast die aufregung eigentlich soll also
jetzt mal ganz platt gefragt hier wird
gefragt rumpel holz auf youtube twitter
weiß ich gerade nicht wahrscheinlich
twitter warum hinterfragt man
demokratische vorgänge und wohlfahrt
einen das ergebnis nicht passte nicht
meint das muss man tatsächlich sagen
alles was da heute passiert ist ist ein
legaler demokratischer vorgang in einer
geheimen wahl kann jeder den
ministerpräsidenten wählen der einpasst
und die afg hat halt jetzt die den
fdp-kandidaten nach vorne gehoben also
da wird teilweise nicht so richtig
verstanden was was diese erschütterung
im politischen berlin und generell in
der politik in deutschland jetzt
ausmacht können sie das noch mal
versuchen zu erklären wie er zum einen
hat man ja in deutschland ist man in
gewisser weise belastet durch die
geschichte insofern gibt es ja auch eine
klare absicht der meisten politischen
akteure sich ganz entschieden von
rechtsextremismus abzugrenzen
und das ist eben bei der afg besonders
in thüringen nicht der fall wo es eben
keine klare abgrenzung rechnung
rechtsextremismus gibt und sogar an den
rhein
tatsächlich menschen sind die
rechtsextremisten extremistische
gesinnung hegen das ist das eine und das
andere ist eben das was ich auch schon
sagte also warum denn da nicht im
vorfeld die überlegungen die koalitions
strategischen überlegungen transparent
ein stückweit transparenter machen und
sagen wir treten jetzt mit dem fdp
kandidaten an der versucht zu vermitteln
zwischen den verschiedenen positionen
und wir bemühen uns um mehrheiten im
landtag
warum hat man das nicht gemacht das
hätten wir noch machen können das ist im
grunde auch die frage die die cdu-chefin
aufgeworfen hat und meinte das war jetzt
ein fehler so anzutreten man hat damit
das ergebnis jetzt ermöglicht es gab ja
auch jetzt diverse aufforderung an herrn
kemmerich das amt niederzulegen also
quasi gerade frisch gewählt und wir das
auch zu sagen sorry waren fehler mache
ich doch nicht die grünen zum beispiel
haben das geforderte teile der grünen
ist es möglich kann jetzt einfach
zurückziehen da wird noch mal neu
gewählt oder wie wir jetzt quasi der
ablauf wenn er sich dazu entscheiden
entscheiden würde ja die war jetzt
angenommen insofern wird man jetzt schon
schauen wollen was er dafür überlegung
hat in den nächsten tagen was da kommt
wie das ganze ausgestaltet werden soll
aber es kann keiner gezwungen werden
ministerpräsident zu bleiben
insofern kann er zurücktreten und kann
die vertrauensfrage stellen
und wenn er sich eben da kein
ausreichendes vertrauen findet kann es
zur neuwahl kommen dass der landtag hat
auch das recht sich selbst aufzulösen
also das wäre auch in den weg zu einer
neuwahl zu kommen
nur ist eben die befürchtung wenn man
eine neuwahl hat das ist nicht unbedingt
zu einem anderen ergebnis führen was
sondern dass man dann vielleicht
parteien gestärkt sieht die man nicht
unbedingt noch stärker sehen möchte also
das ist ein risiko was natürlich in der
neubau liegt und dann müsste man auch
noch zur frage sagen wenn man sich das
international vergleichend anschaut dann
ist es ja tatsächlich so dass wenn
populistische rechtspopulistische
parteien an die macht gekommen sind und
sieht es nicht allein geschafft haben in
der regel konservative parteien nicht
steigbügelhalter aber zumindest mit
beteiligt waren dass es zu diesen macht
übernahmen kommen konnte und insofern
sehen wir jetzt in thüringen dass
deutschland da vielleicht keine ausnahme
von gewesen ist
herr höhne vielen dank für ihre
antworten wir haben zwar noch viele
fragen aber wir müssen das studio in
berlin träumen für das zdf spezial was
es gleich noch gibt da werden dann
wahrscheinlich noch mehr fragen
beantwortet wir werden noch neue
statements haben von daher lohnt sich
das dranbleiben dieser abend heute und
auch morgen glaube ich für ziemlich
spannend erhöhen vielen dank nach berlin
und euch danke für eure fragen euren
kommentaren und fürs zuschauen
ich sag bis zum nächsten live stream bis
dahin macht gut und tschüss
so und wenn euch dieser live-stream
gefallen hat wir haben noch mehr davon
in der playlist zb hier gibt es einen
über zunehmende gewalt gegen politiker
oder hier über die frage warum so viele
junge thüringer die afg gewählt haben
und natürlich lassen aber da macht die
glocke an und fragen kommentare und so
weiter ist das
[Musik]